- Deux millions de litres de
lait gaspillés en cinq jours, et
ce sont les producteurs laitiers
les grands perdants.
Dans cette ferme, Raphaël Spari
a dû se débarrasser de tout
RAPHAËL SPARIproducteur laitier
- Vendredi passé, on a dû jeter
4200 litres de lait à la
fruit de nos efforts qui est
jeté directement, ça fait mal
au coeur de voir ça.
- So-so-so, solidarité!
- Mercredi, les employés
d'Agropur de Granby ont
declenché une grève général
collective est échue depuis
d'un an et la question
des horaires achoppe avec
l'employeur. Conséquence :
des producteurs laitiers
se retouvent sans endroit
où transformer lvente.vente.ven.
BERNARD COURNOYER, Centrale des
syndicats démocratiques
- Nous autres, on en est bien
que... ils sont en grève de même
pour le fun. Si on sort en
greve, c'est parce qu'il y a
des enjeux, des enjeux
importants qui visent
des grévistes.MYLÈNE DUPÉRÉ, v..
corporatives chez Agropur
- Nous sommes ouverts à trouverr
de vraiment limiter le
gaspillage alimentaire.
- Un gaspillage alimentaire qui
arrive au moment où tout coûte
plus cher pour le consommateur.
- C'est nous qui le produisons,
on travaille vraiment fort pour
produire ce lait-là, puis on
doit le jeter à la poubelle.Ça e
pas eux autres qui doivent
dépenser de l'argent pour
l'acheter.
- Insérer une réglementation
au pays est une mesure à adopter
pour certains.
SYLVAIN CHARLEBOIS
expert en agroalimentaire
- Le gaspillage de lait à
devrait être illégal
au Canada. Au Canada,
contrairement à d'autres pays,
c'est pratiquement un bien
public, là. Le lait qui est
versé dans les égouts, c'estdu .
YANNICK GRÉGROIRE, fédération
producteurs de lait du Québec
- Les producteurs ne sont pas
assis à la table pour négocier
les conditions de travail
de cette usine-là.
Et c'est eux, par contre, qui
doivent supporter le fardeau
de ce conflit de travail-là.
Donc, on demande aux parties
prenantes de trouvhode
pour pouvoir prendre un minimum
de lait, pour éviter qu'on se
retrouve dans une situation
qu'on doive faire du gaspillage.
- D'ici là, les syndiqués ont
bien l'intention de tenir
leur bout tant qu'une entente
ne sera pas trouvée.
Ici Danielle Kadjo,
Radio-Canada, Mon